We've learned about ARIA roles,
Design Patterns, live regions, labeling
mechanisms, and ways to hide parts of
the page from assistive technology.
Now we're going to put all of that
together by building on the modal dialog
from Lesson 2 to create
a fully semantic dialog
with a confirmation message
which appears on submit.
Remember that modal dialog that
Rob showed us in Lesson two?
We're going to look at it in
the context of a more complicated page.
So here, we have the familiar
flight booking page, and
we've added a sign up button here.
I'll start Chrome box light and
then tab through these links
to get to the sign up button.
>> Frequent flyer number.
Add a text.
>> I can press Enter or
Space to click the button which
pops open the modal dialog.
It focuses the first focusable element,
and tells me about that element.
Frequent flier number, edit text.
It doesn't give me any information
about the context for that form field.
In this case, we can get by without it.
But it would have been nice to hear this
heading, and to know that we were in
a modal dialog and couldn't get to
the rest of the page without closing it.
I can use the Chrome Vox like
controls to work backwards to explore
the context for this form and see if
there's anything important in there.
>> Log into kangaroo
kilometers heading one
>> So going backwards,
I hear the heading log into
Kangaroo Kilometers, great.
Was there anything else I missed?
I'll hit previous again.
>> Copyright 2015 Udacity,
Internal link footer.
>> Okay.
Now I'm outside the dialogue
in the footer, what the?
Since Chrome Vox isn't directly
moving focus in this case,
our nice focus trapping code
didn't get triggered and
we were able to break
out of the dialogue.
So we have a couple of
issues we need to fix here.
We aren't told we're in a dialogue and
we can break out of the dialogue
with the screen reader.
Have a think back over this lesson, and
have a look at the hints in the code and
see if you can figure out
how we can fix these issues.
Once you fix the example,
come back here and
pick all the statements which are true.